We brought 150 devils in from the wild.
They are placed across a number of zoos
and wildlife parks,
large free-range enclosures where devils
can live in a semi-natural environment
but still at much higher density than they do in the wild, breed up and live in a natural state.
These are all components of what we call an insurance population
and it's an insurance meta-population -
there are many small populations.
So if the disease gets
into one, we can still save the Tasmanian devil in others.
The point of the devil insurance program
and Devil Ark, is to keep devils safe in captivity
before they're released to the wild, when deemed necessary.
Now, one of the most critical components
of that is that devils remain as wild devils, behaviourally.
That we can take a devil from Devil Ark,
put it back into the Tasmanian
wilderness and it survives
it knows how to find food, it knows how to
breed,
it knows where water is, it knows how to find shelter.
It's critical that we retain those wild behaviours.